bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat nous sommes ensemble
jusqu'à 16h30 après midi spécial à
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
avec nous pour nous accompagner
frédérique espagnac bonjour c'est notre
socialiste des pyrénées-atlantiques
merci d'être avec vous à les interpeller
le gouvernement dans un instant sur le
comité interministériel au ruralité qui
s'est tenue lundi à vesoul on va en
parler dans un instant mais avant cela
on va tout de suite retrouvé perrine
tarneaud en direct de la salle des
conférences bonjour perrine alors quel
est le programme de cette première
séance de questions d'actualité depuis
eh bien la seconde session
extraordinaire qui s'est ouvert la
semaine dernière exactement premières
questions d'actualité depuis le début du
mois de septembre ici au sénat des
questions d'actualité qui vont bien sûr
être dominé par la crise migratoire
croire que traverse actuellement
l'europe il y à deux questions adressées
au ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve qui est là qui est arrivé on
l'a vu traverser cette salle des
conférences il y à quelques instants
donc deux questions une de david
assouline pour le groupe socialiste du
sénat et puis une du sénateur
non-inscrit stéphane ravier sénateurs
front national donc voilà pour les deux
questions qui concernent la crise
migratoire une question pour démarrer
cette séance des questions d'actualité
concernant la réforme du code du travail
c'est le sénateur communiste dominique
watrin qui interpelle le gouvernement
c'est jean marie le guen le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
qui lui répondra en l'absence du premier
ministre manuel valls qui est en
déplacement en suède aujourd'hui et puis
parmi les thèmes abordés également cet
après midi au sénat lors de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
est bien une question autour de la
ruralité du déplacement de françois
hollande cette semaine à vesoul mais je
crois que vous allez en parler avec
votre invité frédérique espagnac et puis
également une question du sénateur de
l'hérault jean pierre grand sur les
inondations qui ont durement frappé ce
département de l'hérault cette semaine
donc voilà pour le programme cet après
midi delphine à noter qu'à partir du
mois d'octobre et bien il y aura une
séance de questions d'actu invité par
semaine au sénat le mardi en alternance
avec le jeudi merci beaucoup aux perrine
on vous retrouvera avec vos invités en
direct à partir de 16h pour toutes les
réactions frédérique espagnac on le
disait il ya donc cette question vous
allez poser dans un instant sur ce
comité interministériel au ruralité
c'est la deuxième fois que le
gouvernement se décentraliser il y avait
eu l'an dans l'aisne cette fois c'est à
vesoul en haute-saône que la moitié du
gouvernement s'est rendu avec le chef de
l'état est-ce que les territoires ruraux
ont été les oubliés du quinquennat de
françois hollande jusqu'à présent non je
ne peux pas dire que françois hollande
qui était à la fois maire de tulle et
président du conseil général de corrèze
soit pas sensible à ce genre de
problématique là je crois que c'est pas
un hasard d'ailleurs si il a décidé
c'est quand même une première que de
prendre la présidence du comité
interministériel donc d'habitude c'est
le premier ministre donc ça prouve bien
qu'elle est aujourd'hui une priorité
c'est vrai qu'on est en décalage et ce
qui se passe sur les réfugiés mais je
crois que c'est une question majeure
aujourd'hui sur notre territoire on a
une réalité le sentiment en tout cas
d'une population qui décroche et puis
aussi au quotidien des services publics
qui sont la conséquence qui
disparaissent petit à petit qu'ils sont
la conscience qu'il faut peut-être le
rappeler des politiques menées par
nicolas sarkozy par la rgpp voilà voilà
on est les en est l'exemple confrontés
dans chacun de nos territoires et pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout jeune femme qui veut
accoucher toute personne qui fait un avc
est en droit d'avoir un hôpital
territoriale proche de chez lui à moins
30 minutes comme l'a dit le président de
la république avoir des services de
proximité des maisons de santé des
maisons service public il faut peut-être
rappeler en france il ya un habitant sur
quatre qui aspirent à vivre dans les
zones rurales c'est pas un hasard c'est
aussi là que la dynamique économique se
recrée paradoxalement avec cette
solidarité ce sens du collectif et je
crois que l'avenir de la france au chi
de la croissance qui qui redémarrait
belle passe par ces territoires là et je
crois que ce qu'il faut savoir les
encourager oui mais ce qu'elle approche
des régionales le chef de l'état bien
n'a pas tenté un peu de reconquérir ces
territoires perdus et dans lesquels
finalement le front national pourrait
aussi faire un bon score les deux choses
le front national il a toujours fait un
bon score rappelez-vous 2002 ça c'est
une réalité la deuxième chose c'est que
je peux pas réduire ce qui s'est passé
en début de semaine a juste on va dire
une opération de terrain c'est un long
travail qui a été mené faut le rappeler
à la fois au sénat à l'assemblée
nationale c'est une réflexion qui s'est
fait évidemment avec les associations
d'élus mais surtout un travail qui a été
lancé par sylla pinel il ya plus d'un an
les assises de la ruralité j'en étais un
des six co co rapporteurs ensuite y'a
une première interministériel c'est pas
un hasard si un certain nombre de
parlementaires ont demandé au président
de la république d'aller un peu plus
loin par rapport aux annonces qui avait
été fait en mars dernier donc vous voyez
c'est une un travail de longue haleine
et qui a commencé maintenant il ya
quasiment deux ans trois ans en
particulier puis c'est vrai que le mode
ruralité avait réapparu en tout cas sur
le portefeuille ministériel de sylvia
pinel c'est pas un hasard c'était une
demande puisque en effet sur un mystère
de la ville je crois qu'il est important
aussi d'avoir un ministère des ruralités
ont pourtant il ya peut être aussi un
paradoxe on sait que les cévennes
nouvelles mesures en faveur des
territoires ruraux alors satisfaction
des maires ruraux ils voient plusieurs
dossiers avant si on en a parlé le
nouveau l'accès aux services publics
mais pourtant ils s'interrogent aussi
sur cette question de la baisse des
dotations aux collectivités
territoriales et là il ya des
interrogations elles sont légitimes
aussi aussi qu'il ya une grande
mobilisation des élus ce samedi contre
la baisse c'est bien de l'implication de
l'état l'interrogation des élus en
fonctionne à l'heure où la voie au
quotidien on la voit aussi sur les
problématiques évidemment
d'investissements ont c'est en france
que l'endettement est ce qu'il est on
doit faire les efforts les uns des
autres mais c'est pas en termes
d'investissement c'est en terme de
fonctionnement ensuite le président de
république annoncé une hausse de 1,1
milliard fléché en tout cas sur les
territoires c'est par hasard cdz aussi
au niveau de la snsm tva c'est aussi des
aides avec eux vont pas le voir sur la
loi de finances une réflexion sur la dgf
donc sur les petites reconnaît englobait
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
donc ça veut bien dire que à ce jour
tout est pris est pris en main et que de
fait on est aujourd'hui sur une remise à
plat globale des ressources et des
crédits en tout cas potentiellement en
faveur des collectivités locales elle
est là cette grogne cd et nuancé que
l'association des maires de france
emmenée par le sénateur maire de troyes
les républicains françois baroin est
bien mobilisé il y aura une grande
va peut-être rappeler à françois
barrière à la fois que le ler gpc pas
les socialistes qui l'ont lancée et au
delà des polémiques parce que c'est pas
l'intérêt ce qui est important ce sont
les habitants dans ces territoires là et
globalement dans chacune de nos communes
la réalité aussi c'est qu'on paie une
politique qui a été menée et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui à un moment donné au lieu
d'avoir peut être rationalisée
l'argent l'état potentiellement et il le
financement des collectivités locales on
peut aussi se poser la question en tant
que socialiste je peux moi-même le faire
sur la réorganisation on va dire sur
l'a9 à la nôtre est derrière sur la loi
de ma femme parce que deux fait
aujourd'hui il ya une réflexion à mener
on a essayé de faire un certain nombre
de mesures on le voit aujourd'hui sur la
réorganisation des régions je vous
rappelle que c'est jean pierre raffarin
qui avait fait un rapport ici au sénat
notamment sur ce sujet là je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une façon de
repenser l'état et les différentes
strates de l'état je crois qu'il faudra
y revenir parce qu'on n'a pas été au
bout françois parent qui est aujourd'hui
bien reçu par jean claude juncker le
président de la commission européenne
mais c'est de plaider la cause des
collectivités est ce que vous vous
attendez par exemple des fonds européens
pour aider les communes mais je crois
que le plan juncker peut aussi servir à
ça et je crois que c'est très important
je vois par exemple mon exemple en
aquitaine alain rousset a été un des
premiers à se saisir du plan juncker
pour justement relancer un certain
nombre d'investissements au niveau de la
région aquitaine donc je crois que le
plan de rigueur est une solution
indéniable et surtout une opportunité à
saisir pour les collectivités locales
sur nos territoires sont à revenir sur
un point qui a été annoncée par françois
hollande lundi le dit vouloir former 700
médecins généralistes aux urgences il
veut également aider 1700 jeunes
médecins à s'installer et bien dans les
zones rurales alors que le sénat examine
en ce moment même le projet de loi santé
ce que ces mesures vous paraissent
suffisantes pour bien combler les
déserts médicaux écoutez je sais pas si
elles sont suffisantes en tout cas
action indispensable je peux vous
garantir aujourd'hui que moi même dans
mon département on a déjà bataillé pour
créer des maisons de santé et au moment
de les inaugurer on n'avait pas les
jeunes médecins qui allait avec donc je
peux vous garantir qu aujourd'hui c'est
un battant une bataille au quotidien et
je crois qu'on doit pouvoir aider à la
fois des jeunes médecins mais aussi des
jeunes enseignants ou enseignante à
s'installer dans ces territoires là ce
sont des qualités de vie c'est aussi un
enseignement qui est décisif pour
permettre en tout cas aux enfants ne pas
décrocher dans ces territoires parce que
c'est malheureusement sur la qui
décrochent les 1er et 2 point de vue
santé vous l'avais dit je crois que les
personnes les plus en difficulté sont
souvent ceux qui militent et en montagne
et dans des endroits très design
désertifier on le dit de niveau santé et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya des jeunes
médecins qui font aussi ce jour là par
amour de leur métier tout simplement
parce que contenter de mesures
incitatives ou des mesures coercitives
est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur la liberté
d'installation des médecins par exemple
coûté pour l'instant je pense qu'on va
déjà incité on va déjà voir ce qui se
passe et puis très vite après
je pense qu'on pourra peut-être pas
c'est un autre niveau mais je déjà
faisons en tout cas un geste positif
toujours pas je suis pas toujours sur la
répression faisant un geste positif moi
je vois en tout cas plein de jeunes qui
sortent en tout cas des facs de médecine
et qui ne cherchent qu'une chose c'est
d'avoir un endroit où tu clairement pour
s'installer ou à leur tendre la main
c'est pas toujours le cas on sait que le
sénat est bien a supprimé en commission
la généralisation du tiers payant c'est
une mesure phare du projet de loi de
touraine a les médecins bien redoute de
devenir de véritables fonctionnaires
avec beaucoup de paperasse est ce que ça
ça peut rendre attractif la profession
c'est une vraie question je vais pas
vous mentir moi même j'ai reçu pas mal
de médecins a quitté en effet qui se
questionnaient beaucoup ce sujet là
alors peut-être moins les jeunes qui
sont habitués aujourd'hui à
l'informatique et à 6,6 et systèmes l'un
les anciens les plus anciens en tout cas
ont indéniablement plus de difficultés
et en même temps considèrent que leur
métier leur vocation c'est pas ça et en
même temps on connaît les avantages du
tiers payant donc il ya des questions
faut-il forcément rendre tout
obligatoire immédiatement c'est pas
toujours la solution bon c'est la
volonté du gouvernement toujours des
fois là aussi on n'est pas toujours
obligés d'imposer je pense qu'on peut y
aller vous n'étiez pas à titre personnel
peut être pour cette généralisation du
tiers payant parce que vos notes voir
mon autre débat est bien qui était
organisé au parlement hier et bien sûr
cette question des réfugiés avec
beaucoup d'annoncés de manuel valls qui
a défendu à la fois à l'idée d'une
france fidèle à ses valeurs la france
terre d'accueil tout en créant peut-être
la surprise en disant qu'il était bien
peut-être pour le rétablissement et
ouvrait la voie au rétablissement à des
contrôles à la frontière est ce que
c'est un ralliement à la position
allemande non je pense que c'est une
décision à la fois lucide et réaliste de
ce qui se passe actuellement au
quotidien on voit bien
nous nos frontières aujourd'hui qui sont
à la fois assailli et en même temps je
pense qu'il faut savoir gérer l'humain
voilà donc il ya un ensemble de mesures
qui sont prises vous avez bien vu qu'ils
avaient d'autres choses à la fois sur
l'hébergement à foix sur les
financements qui sont les aides qui sont
donnés aux collectivités locales
aujourd'hui ou six pour accompagner
l'accueil je crois que c'est très
important je crois qu'il ya un sursaut
en france contrairement à ce qui est dit
qui est très positif je vous rappelle
malheureusement les attentats du début
janvier ben voila je crois qu'il ya
c'est sur ceux-là qui sont je pense
qu'ils prennent souvent les politiques
contre un contre-pied d'ailleurs je
crois contrairement à ce qui est dit est
donc je pense que j'ai ramassé quand la
société française montre le bon chemin
même en politique on pourra consigner
solidarité humanité avec la fermeté
affichée hier par le premier ministre je
crois qu il je crois que oui parce qu'il
ya de la place pour les deux je pense
qu'il faut aujourd'hui de toute façon en
répondrez savoir tendre la main et en
même temps évidemment regarder de près
sans être cas par cas mais regarder de
près clairement ça sert à rien de dire
qu'on va accueillir tout le monde si on
n'est pas en capacité de le faire et en
même temps je crois qu'il ya des gens
qui le
nécessitent plus que douteux où il ya
cette question aussi de la répartition
et bien des réfugiés qui sont arrivés on
sait que pour l'instant ils sont tous en
ile de france c'est une analyse qui
arrive en provenance oui enfin moi dans
les pyrénées atlantiques on en a
quelques uns qui vient d'arriver alors
on va en parler justement puisque le
maire du blanc-mesnil en
seine-saint-denis dans une interview
dans le journal le monde disait bien
qu'il faut assurer peut-être une juste
répartition entre les territoires il
propose d'instaurer des quotas par
région comment accueillez vous cette
proposition
je sais pas je sais pas s'il faut
l'arrivée des quotas par région mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui un travail doit
être fait de toute façon pour équilibrer
sur le territoire voilà un certain
nombre d'arrivées et je pense que deux
fait aussi et les capacités d'accueil
sont pas les mêmes partout et donc je
pense que toute personne en tout cas qui
à la fois envie de tendre la main et
toutes collectivités locales qui se sent
aujourd'hui des disponibilités pour le
faire doit forcément se signaler c'est
ce qu'elles font et de fait je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec le mystère intérieur
les choses se passent plutôt très bien
sur la base du volontariat ont des
cottages revient cette question pour
l'instant volontariat et puis après on
verra bien
ce soir jean pierre raffarin avait dit
notamment d'ailleurs c'était sur public
sénat qu'il proposait bien d'installer
des familles de migrants dans les zones
rurales désertées et là où il y avait
des problèmes de déficit démographique
est ce que c'est une bonne idée je vais
vous dire les zones rurales aujourd'hui
elles peuvent en surprendre beaucoup
c'est souvent celles qui sont déjà les
plus solidaires entre elles donc c'est
souvent celles qui tendent le plus la
main donc s'agit pas de dire alors on va
mettre les zones rurales on va les faire
accueillir parce que donc là il manque
un population vous savez paradoxalement
cette population là elle se pose pas de
questions elle est souvent en difficulté
et elles partagent bien plus facilement
que les autres donc ça peut être dans
les zones rurales mais là encore je
pense que toute personne aujourd'hui mer
et y en a un certain nombre dans les
zones rurales qui est aussi disent nous
on est prêt à en accueillir des familles
le font elles mêmes et donc je pense que
sur ça contrairement à ce que d'ailleurs
la question vous puissiez tout à l'heure
je pense qu'il faut savoir faire
confiance aux français et aux françaises
et de tous bords que ça soit dans
l'urbain dans le périurbain dans nos
banlieues ou en tout cas en zone rurale
vous savez des fonctions ils ont le
coeur sur la main et surtout ils ont le
sens où ce qu'est la france on peut
peut-être pas dire ça finalement des
pays membres de l'union européenne ont
l'impression que l'europe a peut-être
failli à sur cette question des migrants
ça vous et al elle faillit et vacille
c'est ça qui est grave je pense que dans
la période actuelle se dire aujourd'hui
qu'on met peut-être à deux doigts d'une
explosion l'europe à quoi sur ce sujet
là c'est une une aberration totale donc
je crois que angela merkel a raison de
taper du poing sur la table à ce sujet
là et je pense que la france elle-même
doit faire entendre et reconnaître fait
en tout cas défendre ce qu'est l'europe
aujourd'hui dans toutes ces
constitutions et en attendant tous que
les ressorts qui sont les chiens
frédérique espagnac vous restez avec
nous on va tout de suite retrouvé vient
perrine tarneaud qui est toujours celle
des conférences 7 à vous paie rien oui
delphine on vient d'entendre la sonnerie
de l'hémicycle retentir donc la séance
de cette délation des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement va démarrer
d'ici quelques instants par une première
question du sénateur commises dominique
watrin sur la réforme du code du travail
c'est jean marie le guen le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
qui va lui répondre en l'absence du
premier ministre en déplacement en suède
ensuite ce sera bien une question david
assouline sur l'accueil des réfugiés en
europe et en france et là c'est bernard
cazeneuve le ministre de l'intérieur qui
est présent cet après midi au sénat qui
lui répondra il y aura une seconde
question sur cet accueil des réfugiés
à la dernière question de cette séance
elle sera posée par le sénateur front
national stéphane ravier et puis nous
aurons également parmi les thématiques
abordées cet après midi par les
sénateurs est bien la ruralité le
déplacement de françois hollande dont
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure avec
frédérique espagnac il y aura une
question de raymond vall sénateur
radical de gauche parmi également les
questions abordées cet après midi eh
bien je vois que gérard larcher démarre
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement donc on va la suivre
tout de suite sur notre antenne je lis
tes au gouvernement
d'autres séances et retransmise en
direct sur france 3 et public sénat et
je demande à chacun de bien respecter
sur temps ce sera après entraînement
avec ce qui va se passer après un tiers
du 1er octobre mais j'y reviendrai la
parole est maintenant à dominique watrin
pour le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue oui ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
annoncé une loi refondant complètement
le code du travail notamment après le
rapport combrexelle il faudrait
flexibiliser encore plus les rapports
entre salariés employeurs effacer la loi
devant la négociation entre des partis
pourtant par essence inégale ce discours
n'est pas nouveau il est celui de la
droite et du patronat depuis 40 ans la
france serait malade de la rigidité de
son code du travail ce qui expliquerait
tous ces maux faut-il comme en allemagne
permettre aux employeurs de payer des
salaires de 400 euros mensuels ou de 1
euro par jour aux chômeurs de longue
durée le résultat bien sûr était la
réduction du chômage mais à quel prix 12
5 millions de travailleurs pauvres soit
plus d'un travailleur sur cinq et au
royaume uni la voie est la même les
salariés ont du travail certes mais
leurs salaires sont insuffisants pour
vivre dignement monsieur le premier
ministre si le code du travail est
illisible trop lourd pourquoi ne pas le
simplifier en assurant en premier lieu
l'égalité traitement entre les salariés
quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise où la présence syndicale
dans ce système les accords de branche
et d'entreprise ne pourrait qu apporter
du mieux disant social mais vous voulez
faire exactement l'inversé
et puis jeunes insiste là-dessus
certains évoquent l'épaisseur du code du
travail comme justificatif j'ai regardé
1795 pages que dire alors du code du
commerce celui des entreprises qui est
un beau bébé de deux mille sept cent
cinquante pages que personne ne songe à
faire mincir notre inquiétude est donc
totale quant à ces annonces et aux
projets qui nous sera présentée cet
hiver le bruit de fond de cette campagne
médiatique c'est celui du medef qui
sortira seul gagnant d'une telle réforme
vos dénégations ne nous trompe pas et
l'ensemble de l'action de votre
gouvernement nous incite à ne pas vous
croire monsieur le premier ministre pour
quoi alors que vos choix et projets
comme le pacte de compétitivité créé du
chômage pourquoi vous acharnez vous dans
cette voie sans issue vous êtes sensible
aux voix des entrepreneurs mais pourquoi
n'entendez vous pas ceux qui à gauche
propose une alternative au libéralisme
monsieur le premier ministre
allez vous renoncer une fois pour toutes
à sacrifier les droits des salariés sur
l'autel des intérêts patronaux pour mon
répondent je donne la parole à monsieur
jean marie le guen est en charge des
relations avec le parlement monsieur le
ministre
la versant sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur a train je vous prie tout
d'abord de bien vouloir excuser la
ministre du travail myriam el khomri qui
m'a chargé de répondre à vos
interrogations quant à la réforme du
droit du travail envisagée par le
gouvernement le code du travail vous le
savez est là pour protéger les salariés
aussi nous avons la responsabilité
d'assurer l'efficacité de notre économie
de lutter contre le chômage et dans
l'intérêt même des salariés les
entreprises doivent pouvoir s'adapter
aux évolutions de leur environnement et
pour pouvoir s'adapter elles ont besoin
qu'on leur donne la possibilité en
accord avec leurs salariés monsieur le
sénateur d'adapter les règles au plus
près du terrain il faut donc redonner de
la souplesse comme le préconise le
rapport combrexelle en privilégiant la
négociation collective
il s'agit de faire davantage confiance
aux salariés pour apporter des solutions
concrètes
le but ce n'est pas moins de garanties
mais des règles capable d'être adaptée
aux besoins du terrain dans l'intérêt
même de l'entreprise et les salariés
aussi vous le savez la loi continuera de
garantir les mêmes droits pour tous et
d'apporter les mêmes garanties
essentielles il n'y aura pas de moins 10
ans pour les salariés en matière de
salaires le smic sera maintenue ainsi
que les salaires minimaux fixés par
branche il n'est pas question il n'est
pas question de remettre en cause la
durée légale du travail les 35 heures le
président de la république et le premier
ministre ont été très clair je le
réaffirme devant vous
le cdi sera préservé nous ne serons pas
dans ce point de vue nous ne céderons
pas sur cette opération enfin réduire la
complexité du droit ce sera un plus pour
les salariés car quand le droit est trop
complexe il n'est pas connu ils ne
protègent en réalité plus personne les
organisations syndicales le
reconnaissent aussi enfin cette réforme
sera menée évidemment en concertation
étroite avec les tous les acteurs
sociaux la réforme se fera dans le
dialogue quant à son calendrier le
président de la république a annoncé
lors de la remise du rapport combrexelle
que le gouvernement entend des litchis
ferrer avant l'été 2016 ce rapport sera
une base importante pour cette réflexion
mais c'était évidemment avec les
partenaires sociaux que nous rentrerons
en discussion le ministre là ministre du
travail recevra évidemment chacune des
organisations syndicales et patronales
représentatives et écoutera toutes leurs
propositions merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur david assouline
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur nous sommes
ici souvent dans des débats qui
légitimement nous oppose car la gauche
et la droite ce n'est pas la même chose
d'autres fois nous sommes interpellés
sur les fondements de notre identité
collective
d'autres fois nous sommes interpellés
sur les fondements de notre identité
collective sur les valeurs qui fondent
nos engagements qui fondent la
république c'était le cas après les
attentats visant la liberté d'expression
et la fraternité
nous avons répondu par le 11 janvier
notre peuple était à la hauteur ses
dirigeants aussi alors que nous étions
frappés au coeur pas de haine
la foule de la fraternité complice et
responsable battait le pavé aujourd'hui
les victimes directes ou indirectes des
mêmes assassins et de ceux qui les ont
enfanté fuient en masse leur pays et
cherchent refuge en europe et là encore
des centaines de villes solidaires des
associations des milliers de citoyens
prennent des initiatives pourtant de
l'âme à la dignité humaine se trouve là
mais malheureusement souvent les yeux
rivés vers ce qu'ils leur part étaient
leurs intérêts électoraux immédiats
certains préfèrent parler vulgairement
de fuites d'eau
arrivent à comprendre ce qui s'exilent
pour échapper au fisc mais n'arrive pas
à comprendre pourquoi d'autres s'exilent
pour échapper à la mort et aux
persécutions
certains tri entre la religion des uns
et des autres alimente les peurs que
cette instabilité engendre
inévitablement
montrent les pauvres les uns contre les
autres ou par l'invasion barbare
là où notre au nord et d'en appeler à ce
qu'il ya de meilleur au plus profond de
chacun et de notre peuple certains
cherchent à arriver tout ce qu'il y a de
plus égoïste ou malsain alors monsieur
le ministre qui montrait chaque jour je
tenais à le dire que votre fonction
première qui est d'assurer la protection
de nos concitoyens
de rassurer par la plus grande maîtrise
de la situation peut se conjuguer
parfaitement avec cette valeur
essentielle de notre république que la
fraternité dites nous dans l'esprit de
ceux qui ont honoré cette mi6 comme
victor hugo qui fut lui même un exilé
politique
dites-nous ce que la france fait courir
là où elle est attendue par le monde et
pour encourager ce formidable élan de
nos municipalités de nos concitoyens
de l'intérieur pour répondre monsieur
bernard cazeneuve la parole monsieur le
sénateur assouline vous souligne à
l'instant l'étendue d'un drame
humanitaire que nous voyons se déployer
sous nos yeux depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines avec des tragédies
des femmes des enfants des populations
en situation de vulnérabilité
qui entre les mains de passeurs mais
aussi surtout parce qu'ils sont
persécutés dans leur pays prennent le
chemin de l'exode arrive en europe pour
pouvoir continuer à vivre et ceux qui
franchissent les frontières extérieures
de l'union européenne notamment en grèce
sont les persécutés de dèche du califat
de la haine et du régime de bachar
el-assad donc quel est notre devoir
qu'elle nos stratégies notre devoir
d'abord c'est conformément à ce qu est
la france à ce que le message
multiséculaire qu'elle a appris à tenir
aux peuples du monde d'accueillir ceux
qui sont persécutés de le faire dans une
solidarité européenne renforcée pour
cela nous nous sommes engagés au plan
national à travers la loisil qui permet
de réduire considérablement
la durée de traitement des dossiers des
demandeurs d'asile de 24 9 mois en
créant 18 mille cinq cents places en
centres d'accueil pour demandeurs
d'asile
au cours du quinquennat en donnant des
moyens supplémentaires à aux
administrations en charge de l'accueil
des demandeurs d'asile pour pouvoir
atteindre l'objectif de la réduction des
délais je pense notamment à l'ofpra et à
l'ofii nous avons avec sylvia pinel
présenter un plan de création de onze
mille places supplémentaires
d'accueil dans le logement de droit
commun pour sortir les réfugiés des cada
ou des centres d'hébergement d'urgence
en augmentant les places en cada en
créant aussi des places en hébergement
d'urgence à hauteur de 1500 et puis il
ya la dimension européenne qui doit
permettre de conjuguer
humanité et fermeté
d'abord en créant les conditions du
mécanisme de répartition
des réfugiés entre les différents pays
de l'union européenne ça a été une
proposition française elle a été reprise
par la commission nous devons aboutir à
une solution au prochain conseil justice
et affaires intérieures de mardi
deuxièmement en mettant en place de
véritables actions de contrôle des
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne qui permet d'identifier les
réfugiés et de procéder à la reconduite
à la frontière de ce qui ne relève pas
du statut du réfugié en europe parce que
s'il n'y a pas de fermeté et de
responsabilité là où il ya de la
générosité il n'y a pas de soutenabilité
de l'accueil des réfugiés je voudrais
conclure en disant que sur cette
question des migrations face à des
drames d'humanitaire comme ceux auxquels
nous sommes confrontés il ya parfois
beaucoup d'approximations beaucoup
d'imprécisions beaucoup de manipulations
et je forme le voeu que dans cet
hémicycle nous avons plus ré c'est de le
faire hier nous puissions nous
rassembler parce que lorsque l'essentiel
est en cause il faut être capable de
dire ensemble merci la parole et à
monsieur olivier cadic pour le groupe de
l'union démocrate et indépendant union
centriste si monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des affaires sociales
la semaine dernière la france a
découvert le calvaire du petit bastien
trois ans son père l'a tuée en
l'enfermant dans un lave linge qui l'a
mis en marche quand ce père a téléphoné
aux pompiers il leur a dit qu'il avait
un petit souci
s'il avait un petit souci nous avons
nous tous collectivement un gros
problème avec la maltraitance
il y a deux ans un colloque national sur
les violences faites aux enfants s'est
tenue au sénat il a donné lieu à un
rapport qui a été présenté à madame la
ministre marisol touraine ce rapport
indique je cite qu'il manque encore en
france un outil statistique nationale
pour mesurer l'ampleur du problème du
danger et de la maltraitance
entre cette date et aujourd'hui on
estime que 1500 enfants sont morts en
france sous les coups de parents
bourreaux il y en aura deux de plus ce
soir deux de plus demain à l'échelle du
quinquennat nous parlons d'une hécatombe
équivalente à celle du rance septembre
deux enfants meurent chaque jour en
france de mauvais traitements au royaume
uni ces deux par semaine là bas des
acteurs sociaux et la justice sont tenus
d'intervenir à la première alerte des
mesures de sauvegarde sont prises au
moindre soupçon
compte tenu des observations de nos
services sociaux outre manche ils
auraient été tenus de retirer bastien a
la garde de ses parents le système
français a failli jacques toubon le
défenseur des droits a réclamé au
président de la république de faire de
la lutte contre la maltraitance une
cause nationale
madame la ministre il y a quelques jours
la photo du petit elian trouvé mort sur
une plage turc a ému la communauté
internationale sur le sort des migrants
à melun la juge a fait projeter aux
jurés les photos du corps martyrisé du
petit bastien faut-il publier ces photos
pour obtenir un sursaut des pouvoirs
publics pourriez-vous nous dire la dame
la ministre si vous allez enfin mettre
en place un outil statistique de suivi
de la maltraitance pourriez-vous nous
dire quelles mesures vous envisagez de
prendre pour mieux prévenir et combattre
la maltraitance en france allez vous en
faire une priorité nationale merci pour
vous répondre la parole et klm leur
autre fille
et quand elle était en charge de la
famille de l'enfance les personnes âgées
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur olivier
cadic d'abord je voulais vous remercier
de poser cette question et d'évoquer
dans cette assemblée le martyre du petit
bastien ce qu'il a subi mérite que nous
prononcions son prénom aujourd'hui bien
sûr lorsqu'un drame de cette nature
survient la première question qu'on se
pose c'est comment est ce possible pas
simplement comment est ce possible qu'il
y ait des parents qui assassinent leurs
enfants malheureusement nous savons que
ça existe mais comment est-ce possible
que les services sociaux qui pourtant
suivez cette famille n'ait pas pu
prévenir ce qui est arrivé
avant peut-être que l'on identifie les
dysfonctionnements qui peuvent conduire
à ce type de drame peut-être il faut
rappeler que la protection de l'enfance
en france protège chaque année 300 mille
enfants et que tous les jours elle sauve
des enfants etc avant que nous parlions
des dysfonctionnements avant que nous
parlions des faits divers il faut dire
quand même que les travailleurs sociaux
en france les politiques publiques que
nous conduisons les départements
agissent chaque jour et que nous sommes
fiers de cette politique bien sûr il ya
des erreurs des erreurs de diagnostic
mais dans toutes les professions ça peut
rêver malheureusement vous m'interrogez
pour savoir quand allons-nous donner une
priorité à la protection de l'enfance
monsieur le sénateur s'est fait et d'un
certain point de vue c'est fait aussi
grâce à cette assemblée
l'année dernière nous avons sur la base
des rapports de muguette dini qui était
sénatrice ici et de l'udi et de michel
meunier sénatrice socialiste engagé une
réforme à la fois législatives et une
réforme des pratiques des professionnels
car on ne change pas les pratiques
uniquement par la loi depuis un an j'ai
concertée rencontrer l'ensemble des
professions j'ai rencontré les anciens
enfants de l'ace j'ai rencontré les
parents d'enfants placés les magistrats
les travailleurs sociaux et la
proposition de loi qui est la grande
réforme n'a pas qu'ils sont de l'enfance
l'acte 2 d'un certain point de vue
depuis la réforme de philippe bas sera
adoptée par le sénat une feuille de
route avec 100 actions a été présenté à
l'ensemble des professions est à la fois
le repérage précoce de la maltraitance
le suivi de la maltraitance la
prévention de la répétition de la
maltraite danse sont au coeur de nos
priorités de cette réforme je suis
convaincu qu'elle aboutira et elle
aboutira parce que je n'ai pas conduite
seul et d'en haut parce que je les
conduites sur la base du travail
effectué par les parlementaires et
surtout avec l'ensemble des
professionnels dans une concertation qui
va permettre que nous réussissions cette
réforme je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre la parole est à notre collègue
jacques legendre pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur nous avons tous
été émus par le drame qui s'est produit
fin ou dans un camp de gens du voyage à
roye dans la somme et qui a coûté la vie
à trois personnes de cette communauté a
battu par un forcené et un gendarme qui
tentait de s'interposer
mais l'émotion ne peut pas excuser les
incidents qui ont suivi à l'occasion de
l'enterrement des victimes
parce que la justice n'avait pas
autorisé deux parents des victimes
condamné à de la prison a assisté aux
obsèques des membres de cette communauté
ont coupé le 28 ou l'autoroute a1 paris
lille dans les deux sens causant
d'importants dégâts à la chaussée et
provoquant 50 km de bouchons sur l'a1
l'a16 et l'a29 pendant des heures en
cette soirée de grand retour de vacances
sur ordre du préfet la gendarmerie n'est
pas intervenue et n'a procédé à aucune
interpellation
quant à la cour d'appel elle s'est
réunie en urgence pour revenir sur la
décision du juge d'application des
peines et autoriser les personnes
incarcérées a assisté aux obsèques
une telle affaire pose bien des
questions pourquoi la justice at-elle
refusé ce qu'elle a ensuite accepté en
urgence pourquoi les forces de l'ordre
ne sont elles pas intervenu alors qu'il
y avait un trouble manifeste à l'ordre
public
quel le coût de cette affaire qui va
payer les travaux de remise en état de
l'autoroute qui va compenser les pertes
de recettes que la société
concessionnaire peut réclamer monsieur
le président de la république
questionné à ce sujet s'est déclaré
profondément désolé pour les
désagréments causés mais a déclaré ne
pas vouloir mettre en danger les forces
de l'ordre nous le comprenons bien mais
cet aveu de faiblesse c'est quand même
très inquiétant il rappelle la choquante
mansuétude dont ont bénéficié les
hadîths notre dame des landes en loire
atlantique où plus de 200 exactions ont
été commises y compris fin ou contre des
gendarmes sans véritable réaction des
autorités
ont une que dire de la situation aussi à
calais le 2 septembre quant à l'entrée
dû tunnel sous la manche un eurostar
avec 704 passagers à bord est resté
bloqué de 21h30 à 10h30 le lendemain
matin à cause de la présence de migrants
sur les voies monsieur le ministre quand
l'autorité reculent devant les violents
c'est la république qui s'affaiblit
défendre la république c'est d'abord
faire appliquer la loi
pour vous répondre par an le fameux
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve pour 2030 maximum
monsieur le monsieur le sénateur
legendre vous êtes un excellent
commentateur d'une situation que vous
avez avec vos amis contribuer à créer et
je vais m'expliquer ouais je vais
m'expliquer
parce que monsieur le sénateur legendre
quand quand pendant cinq ans quand
pendant cinq ans on supprime pas quand
pendant cinq ans on supprime 15 unités
de forces mobiles 15 unités de forces
mobiles quand pendant cinq ans on
supprime 13 mille agents dans les forces
de l'ordre 7000 dans la gendarmerie et
6000 dans la police quand pendant cinq
ans avec une méticulosité
absolue on s'emploie à affaiblir les
forces de l'ordre on se dispense de
donner des leçons à ceux qui doivent
faire face à une situation difficile et
qui mobilise des forces de l'ordre pour
y faire face c'est ça la réalité
deuxièmement deuxièmement vous n'étiez
pas là le soir où s'est passé ce drame j
étais moi à l'hôpital d'amiens j'étais
aux côtés des gendarmes qui avaient
perdu l'un des leurs et j'ai vu
l'émotion parmi les forces de
gendarmerie
au moment où ce drame s'est produit j'ai
également vu le climat d'extrême tension
qui existait à ce moment là et il est
des moments où il est de la
responsabilité de l'état de ne pas
ajouter des morts aux morts est de faire
en sorte lorsqu'il ya une situation de
ce type d'être dans la responsabilité
plutôt que d'être dans l'exploitation
d'une situation à des fins politiques
avec des arguments populistes qui sont
ceux que vous venez d'utiliser à
l'instant enfin le troisième argument
que je voudrais développer monsieur le
sénateur et je vais vous le dire très
franchement laissé à penser que sur ce
sujet il puisse y avoir une quelconque
faiblesse de l'état alors même qu'au
lendemain de cet événement les enquêtes
ont été enclenchées qu'elle se
poursuivre pour rattraper ceux qui ont
commis ces actes et les punir les plus
sévèrement possible c'est aussi
alimenter un populiste qui ne fait pas
de bien à la république
bien la parole
est maintenant remis à monsieur raymond
vall
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole et vous seuls merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
dans les territoires ruraux dont le gers
que j'ai l'honneur de représenter à
nouveau dans cette haute assemblée nos
concitoyens ressentent qu'ils sont des
oubliés des politiques d'aménagement de
territoire depuis des dizaines d'années
ce sentiment il faut bien l'avouer
certains responsables politiques
longtemps tenu en ne prenant pas en
compte les spécificités rural dans
l'élaboration des dernières lois je
pense à la loi ma part mais la loi nôtre
où certains articles et est inapplicable
dans la ruralité
aujourd'hui enfin la ruralité est une
priorité affichée du président de la
république du gouvernement et la prise
de conscience pour la france que ce
territoire représente aussi une source
de développement économique des
ressources énergétiques y compris
renouvelables des gisements d'innovation
une agriculture indispensable dans le
gers le 29 juillet dernier je suis le
premier ministre vous avez confirmé
votre volonté de prendre en compte le
handicap de la spécificité rurale telle
que l'enclavement l'absence
d'infrastructures la disparation des
services publics la certification
médicale et le dernier comité
interministériel dédié à la ruralité qui
s'est tenue à vesoul au début de cette
semaine à confirmer et préciser un
certain nombre de mesures en faveur de
ces territoires je pense notamment au
soutien de l'investissement de nos
collectivités durement touchée par la
baisse de leurs dotations mais aussi au
nécessaire renforcement de la présence
des services publics de proximité les
habitants des territoires ruraux
attendent la reconnaissance du principe
d'égalité républicaine il ne pourrait y
avoir de citoyens de seconde classe dans
notre république
monsieur le premier ministre madame la
ministre merci nous dix ans quel moyen
longuement entente il mettre rapidement
en oeuvre pour redonner espoir à ces
territoires ruraux et à ceux qui y
vivent et re motiver des élus locaux
particulièrement les mères qui sur ces
territoires assume une mission
républicaine
irremplaçable pour nos concitoyens
merci pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame sylvia pinel
ministre du logement de l'égalité des
territoires de la ruralité merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur raymond vall permettez moi tout
d'abord de
féliciter chaleureusement pour votre
élection récente dans le gers et je suis
heureuse de vous retrouver dans cet
hémicycle et je sais combien vous êtes
attaché au développement des territoires
ruraux vous avez rappelé leurs
spécificités mais surtout les moyens de
répondre aux attentes des élus locaux et
de leurs habitants je peux vous assurer
que le gouvernement partage votre
volonté d'accompagner l'ensemble des
territoires et en particulier les
territoires ruraux comme vous l'avez dit
pour le gouvernement la république c'est
l'ensemble des territoires c'est
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et il n'y
a pas de territoire ou de citoyens de
seconde classe nous l'avons rappelé avec
le président de la république et le
premier ministre lundi à vesoul ce
comité interministériel était l'occasion
de dresser un bilan des 46 premières
mesures concrètes que nous avions
présenté en mars mais aussi de faire le
point sur leur déploiement et celles qui
sont déjà opérationnels parmi celles là
vous en avez cité un certain nombre
d'exemples beaucoup a été fait dans les
dernières lois que vous avez d'ailleurs
adopté ici dans cette assemblée je
prends l'exemple de l'ingénierie la mise
en place du dispositif et des qui permet
de soutenir à la fois les élus locaux
mais aussi les porteurs de projets dans
des dossiers souvent complexes qui ne
peuvent pas être mené localement un
dispositif expérimental a été lancée
déjà trois départements sont concernés
l'ariège la lozère et la nièvre ce
travail bien sûr doit se poursuivre et
s'amplifier c'est le sens des
vingt-et-une nouvelles mesures annoncées
par le président de la république parmi
celles ci le fonds d'un milliard pour
soutenir l'investissement des communes
et des intercommunalités
la moitié sera fléché vers les
territoires ruraux
parmi ces mesures trois cents millions
d'euros seront réservés à
l'accompagnement et à la revitalisation
des centres bourgs et des petites villes
nous proposons également l'élargissement
du fonds de compensation de la tva aux
dépenses d'entretien des bâtiments
publics des collectivités
vous le voyez la détermination du
président de la république et de
l'ensemble du gouvernement est totale
pour être aux côtés des habitants aux
côtés des élus locaux des territoires
ruraux pour donner tout son sens à
l'égalité des territoires c'est une
notion essentielle dans notre république
merci même si la parole est un monsieur
joël labbé pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs ma
question s'adresse à stéphane le foll
ministre de l'agriculture et concerne
bien évidemment la question de
l'agriculture qui a fait l'actualité
depuis le printemps pendant tout l'été
et de manière très vive à cette rentrée
cela monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture vous en savez quelque
chose lors de la réunion exceptionnelle
que vous aviez provoqué à bruxelles le 7
le 7 septembre vous allez plaidé plutôt
pour des mesures de régulation publique
plutôt que des aides directes mais la
commission fidèle au dogme libéral ne
vous a pas suivi si les mesures
financières nécessaires ont contribué à
certain apaisement la grande souffrance
les grandes difficultés financières le
désespoir dû au manque de perspectives
restent toujours présent auprès d'une
partie importante du monde agricole il
convient d'évoquer ici ceux qui sont en
réelle difficulté ils ne le sont pas
tous la disparité sont d'ailleurs énorme
en agriculture ce qui rend la crise la
plus insupportable encore et le comble
du cynisme c'est que certains
instigateurs des manifestations et non
des moindres ont contribuer à la mise en
place de mécanismes qui ont entraîné
cette situation de détresse il convient
de le dire si une partie du monde
agricole va très mal c'est lui qui qui
lui est liée de l'agrochimie de
l'agro-industrie celui de l'agro
business se porte pas si mal et les
affaires de l'interlocuteur majeurs du
monde agricole qu'est le président
xavier beulin aviez bollain je crois
savoir qu'elles vont plutôt bien
d'ailleurs nous pourrons l'interroger en
direct la semaine prochaine parce que
nous allons l'entendre dans le cadre de
la commission des affaires économiques
j'espère que dans la foulée nous
entendrons aussi les autres syndicats
agricoles
aujourd'hui deux logiques s'affrontent
entre une agriculture dite moderne de
plus en plus industrialisés porté par
toujours plus de technologie de
mécanisation et de produits chimiques
l'une agriculture dite de la croissance
de la compétitivité de l'exportation et
l'autre agriculture familiale et
paysanne tout aussi moderne mais d'une
autre manière en lien avec la terre en
lien avec les territoires celles basées
sur ces sur des systèmes qui font
aujourd'hui leurs preuves votre question
alors ma question est quelque peu
abrupte mais claire entendez vous
monsieur le ministre
contribuer à ce que les politiques
françaises et européennes sortent de la
cogestion et puis se libérer de ce
puissant lobby et entendre enfin
l'ensemble de la représentation agricole
à travers les syndicats minoritaires
aussi et entendent aussi les aspirations
de la société civile je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre stéphane le foll
les listes de l'agriculture vont
répondre vous avez la parole ce
président est monsieur le sénateur je
suis très satisfait du pays et posé
cette question les sujets agricoles
ayant
était vous l'avez remarqué au coeur de
l'actualité cet été je souhaite
d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui ont passé de
bonnes vacances
d'être revenu avec beaucoup d'énergie
pour pouvoir aborder tous les sujets
importants qui sont à l'ordre du jour je
n'en doute pas je voudrais vous répondre
le sénateur sur
le début de la question en fait qui
était plutôt une affirmation sur ce qui
s'est passé en particulier à bruxelles
et considérer que c'est vrai que dans le
conseil européen aujourd'hui par rapport
aux objectifs que nous avion avec sept
huit pays on a eu affaire au niveau de
la commission européenne et d'un certain
nombre d'autres pays à un refus
d'inverser ce qu'est le paquet qui a été
proposé au niveau européen c'est à dire
un paquet qui porte sur des aides et des
soutiens aux agriculteurs plutôt que de
mettre l'accent sur des mécanismes et
des aides directement liés à la
régulation du marché c'est ce que j'ai
dit et c'est ce que je continuerai à
dire et surtout à faire en sorte de
peser pour que de 7,8 pays on puisse
finir par aboutir à une majorité parce
que c'est la seule condition qu'on aura
à faire changer la commission de
position sur 500 millions d'euros je
vais le rappeler au sénat ces 500
millions d'euros viennent de ce qu'on
appelle le super prélèvements le super
prélèvements c'est ce qu'ont payé un
certain nombre de pays qui après la
suppression des quotas qui ont été
décidées en 2008 et contre lesquels
j'avais voté
des pays avait à respecter une
augmentation de leur production laitière
ils l'ont dépassé c'est une dizaine de
pays et il ya neuf mois il était venu me
voir pour demander que la france les
soutiennent pour ne pas payer de
sanctions j'ai refusé
ayant refusé les sanctions étaient payés
ces 900 millions d'euros ont été dégagés
c'est ce qu'on appelle le super
prélèvements ce qui a permis de dégager
500 millions d'euros aujourd'hui sans
que le budget soit touchée et sans bien
sûr qu'il y ait de contredire que nos
contributions demandées aux autres pays
et en particulier la france je suis
obligé de dire que sur ces sommes 420
millions la france et l'allemagne
d'allemagne a payé 400 millions de super
prélèvements la france 0 la nature et 69
millions la france 63 millions mais
au-delà de ça par rapport à l'objectif
stratégique est ce que la france pèse
pour changer les choses hier à l' ocde
quinze pays ont été réunis dix sept
universitaires et scientifiques pour
porter l'initiative de la france ne peut
la revue le cache du carbone pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
la france agit la france entraîne
si je me nice
la parole est à notre collègue vincent
eblé pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget la
loi de finances rectificative de juin
2014 a abaissé l'impôt sur le revenu des
contribuables en bas de barèmes 1
milliard d'euros ainsi été consacrés aux
ménages les plus modestes en 2015 la
première tranche du barème a été
supprimé
c'est la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
qui a permis de financer ces mesures au
total près de 9 millions et demi de
foyers fiscaux voient ainsi leur
contribution fiscale allégée par rapport
à 2013 trois millions ont évité d'entrer
ou sorte de l'imposition sur les revenus
les bénéficiaires sont principalement
des salariés et des retraités modestes
se sont très souvent eux qui ont du mal
à finir leur mois nous devons bien sûr
les soutenir nous avons l'obligation de
soutenir leur pouvoir d'achat le
président de la république lors de sa
récente conférence de presse a annoncé
une nouvelle étape du mouvement de
baisse d'impôts initié depuis 2014 ces
mesures s'inscrivent donc dans la durée
elles doivent redonner confiance en
l'avenir pour que chaque français puisse
participer à hauteur de ses moyens réels
au redressement de la france à titre
d'exemple les nouvelles mesures
annoncées vont permettre à un couple de
retraités percevant près de 3000 euros
de revenus par mois de voir son impôt
baissé de 500 euros en 2016 monsieur le
ministre à sous le précédent quinquennat
la politique économique menée par le
gouvernement de l'époque avait fait
augmenter la dette de la france de 600
milliards d'euros soit une augmentation
de plus de 40% depuis notre arrivée au
pouvoir nous travaillons à sa réduction
le déficit structurel a été ramené à son
niveau le plus bas depuis 2008 la
nécessité de cet assainissement
budgétaire
n'a de sens que si l'ensemble des
français en profitent notamment les
classes dites moyennes souvent mis à
contribution dans les efforts à fournir
et ressentant particulièrement vivement
la pression fiscale monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous préciser de quelle
manière s'appliqueront les nouvelles
baisses d'impôts annoncées
pour répandre la parole et à christian
eckert secrétaire d'état en charge du
budget le ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs des
sénatrices et les sénateurs sueur
sénateur l'assemblée essayons de faire
un raccourci de l'histoire récente de
notre fiscalité de l'impôt sur le revenu
2007 2007 paquet fiscal bouclier fiscal
cadeau fiscal on vide les recettes
fiscales notamment sur l'impôt sur le
revenu puis la crise et puis
2010-2011 réaction rien les dates sont
importantes 2010 2011 augmentation
d'impôt par quel dispositif gel du
barème gel du barème
demi par des veuves supprimés avec un
étalement dans le temps d'ailleurs
plutôt explosif pour les successeurs
parallèlement d'ailleurs lié s'est fait
vider de sa substance
2012 devant une situation que vous avez
décrite monsieur le sénateur assemblée
effectivement cette majorité poursuit
mais par d'autres méthodes une
augmentation des recettes et quelle
méthode mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
alignement de la fiscalité des revenus
du capital sur ceux du travail
création d'une tranche supplémentaire
d'impôt à 45 % pour les hauts revenus
plafonnement des niches fiscales qui par
essence ne bénéficie qu'à ceux qui
payent de l'impôt sur le revenu oui une
augmentation de la fiscalité mais oui
plus de justice dans cette augmentation
et puis 2014
2014 vous l'avez dit 2015 et maintenant
2016 verront une redistribution vous
l'avez décrit c'est maintenant le coeur
de ceux qui payent de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est à dire les classes moyennes
trois millions de nouveaux contribuables
qui n'avait pas été concerné par les
baisses d'impôts de 2014 et 2015 cette
nouvelle fraction de ceux qui payent
l'impôt sur le revenu vont bénéficier de
réductions oui mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs nous aurons le débat comment
seront financés ces baisses d'impôts
pourquoi cette concentration de la peau
quelques éléments de réponse le
financement c'est effectivement un
second but contre la fraude c'est
effectivement insolent de constation
constatation de nouvelles économies nous
aurons le débat mais aussi mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs pas
d'augmentation pour les autres
contribuables
nous avons effectivement contribuer à
réduire les déficits publics mais dans
un processus qui tient compte de la
justice ait de la progressivité de
l'impôt sur revenu
comme unis la parole est à monsieur jean
pierre grand pour le groupe l'est
républicain
et monsieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
en septembre 2014 de très nombreuses
communes de l'hérault ont été sinistrés
par de violentes intempéries
on a eu à déplorer des victimes ces
épisodes de pluies diluviennes avec les
mêmes effets ravageurs se sont
reproduits fin août a fait route nous
avons eu encore à déplorer de mort à
montpellier samedi à dimanche dernier
mon département était à nouveau durement
frappé par les plus torrentielles en
particulier dans le secteur du lodévois
et dans la vallée de l'hérault avec des
conséquences financières énormes pour
nos communes et de nombreux dégâts pour
les agriculteurs si les communes les
plus urbaines peut faire face à ses
dépenses exceptionnelles mais avec
difficulté c'est totalement impossible
pour les plus petits villages qui le
peuvent assument et l'impérieuse et
urgente remise en état des voiries
communales et des chemins ruraux pour ne
parler que de ces équipements
indispensables et vulnérables les aides
de l'état commencent à arriver pour les
inondations de septembre 2014 un an
après aucun vrai monsieur le ministre
que c'est trop long pour les maires
ruraux le financement reste à la charge
de leur village entre les aides diverses
et le coût réel des travaux est
incompatible avec leur maigre budget
face à la répétition de tels phénomènes
météorologiques il revient à l'état et
au parlement d'imaginer très vite des
réponses nouvelles pour que les plus
petites communes de france puissent
faire face comme toutes les autres à
leurs obligations de service public cela
s'appelle légalité républicaine
de nombreux maires sont désespérés
devant leur impossibilité de financer
les dégâts causés par ces catastrophes
naturelles il est incontournable que
pour ses petites communes rurales les
aides publiques couvre 100 % du coût des
sinistres sur le ministre
est il possible de connaître également
les dates où seront pris les arrêtés de
catastrophe naturelle pour les épisodes
du 23 août et la semaine dernière enfin
je vous demande comment l'état compte
être rendez-vous la solidarité nationale
afin d'aider en urgence les communes les
plus durement touchés ma question se
pose également pour les viticulteurs et
toutes les productions agricoles
sinistrées dans l'hérault votre réponse
monsieur le ministre est attendu par les
élus locaux et par le monde agricole qui
n'en peut plus d'avancé merci pour eux
que ministre de l'intérieur ceux que ce
deuil pour répondre à notre question
appelle des réponses extrêmement précise
d'abord il est vrai que le département
de l'hérault comme le département du
gard ont été frappés par des épisodes
météorologiques extrêmement sérieux et
répéter ça a été notamment le cas la
semaine dernière avec les événements qui
ont frappé le lodévois le ganges
également à proximité des cévennes et
puis dans le département du gard les
communes de vals rogge les communes
d'alès et un certain nombre de communes
aux environs vous insisté sur la
nécessité de procéder rapidement à
l'indemnisation des communes concernées
de manière à ce que la vie puisse
reprendre normalement et je voudrais
vous apporter un certain nombre de
réponses précises d'abord pour ce qui
concerne les événements qui se sont
produits à la fin du mois d'août c'est à
dire qui ont précédé ceux du week-end
dernier la commission interministérielle
se réunira le 22 septembre prochain et
l'ensemble des dossiers qui ont été
portés à la connaissance de l'état
pourront être examinés à cette occasion
deuxième point pour ce qui concerne les
événements dont on vous parlait à
l'instant j'ai donné instruction au
préfet de l'hérault de bien vouloir
prendre contact avec l'ensemble des
communes concernées de manière à ce que
les dossiers d'indemnisation puisse être
complétée le plus rapidement possible il
ya vingt-deux communes avec lesquels il
est d'ores et déjà en contact ce qui
permettra de réaliser très rapidement
ces dossiers de procéder à
l'indemnisation
troisième point à vous insisté sur la
nécessité d'une indemnisation rapide des
communes et notamment sur la possibilité
d' indemniser à 100 % les plus petites
communes pour lesquelles ces événements
météorologiques sont un désastre et
elles ont peu de ressources pour pouvoir
réparer les dégâts occasionnés par ces
tempêtes là aussi des éléments de
réponse concrets j'ai voulu modifier la
procédure qui était trop longue les vous
mêmes souligné et un décret a été pris
le 18 juin 2015 il ya quelques semaines
qui va permettre d'avancer dans trois
directions d'abord les délais
d'instruction seront raccourcis parce
que le délai d expertise sera moins
important et le processus d'expertisé
sera considérablement simplifié
deuxièmement j'ai demandé à ce que l'on
augmente le niveau des avances faites
aux communes et troisièmement j'ai
demandé à ce que l'on puissent fusionner
les fonds d'indemnisation dans le cadre
de la loi de finances pour 2016 pour ce
qui concerne les agriculteurs le
dispositif calamités agricoles en
liaison avec le ministère de
l'agriculture sera enclenchée très
rapidement enfin pour ce qui concerne
les petites communes
répondant à la préoccupation par
anticipation qui est la vôtre j'ai
inscrit dans le décret du 18 juin 2015
la possibilité de procéder à
l'indemnisation à 100%
des travaux à réaliser pour ces petites
communes au terme des dégâts occasionnés
par les tempêtes les préoccupations que
vous exprimez sont tout à fait légitimes
et le gouvernement a souhaité y répondre
au regard des catastrophes qui sont
produits notamment dans votre
département en 2014 et qui ont conduit
d'ailleurs ces événements
météorologiques à l'indemnisation des
communes de l'hérault pour 2014 à
hauteur de 14,1 millions d'euros merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à notre collègue
frédérique espagnac pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues la question s'adresse à madame
sylvia pinel ministre l'égalité des
territoires le 14 septembre dernier le
gouvernement a organisé un second comité
interministériel au ruralité à vesoul ce
comité interministériel intervient suite
aux assises de la ruralité lancé en
septembre 2014 dont j'ai été une des co
rapporteur à la demande de plusieurs
parlementaires et afin d'aller plus loin
dans ses mesures le gouvernement a
décidé d'organiser six mois après un
second comité 1/2 interministériel
ruralité cette fois ci en présence du
président de la république qui s'est
saisie pleinement du dossier je ne peux
que me réjouir et salué ce signe fort de
replacer les territoriaux qu au coeur
des priorités nationales celles ci
doivent impérativement lutter contre le
sentiment d'abandon que peuvent
ressentir les habitants des communes
rurales en important et garantissant un
service public de qualité pour tous
la ruralité est une chance pour la
france c'est une de ses richesses là on
croit avoir une france en déclin c'est
aujourd'hui un paysage nouveau qui
apparaît une partie de l'avenir de notre
pays se joue dans ces territoires il
nous faut faire rupture avec le passé et
maintenir des systèmes de santé avec des
hôpitaux de territoire les doter des irm
scanner comme dans l'urbain veillez
aussi au maintien des effectifs dans les
écoles rurales ces territoires doivent
bénéficier de nouvelles infrastructures
on ne laissons pas les opérateurs est
les seuls décideurs il nous faut enfin
générer de nouvelles implantations
veillez à la dé métropolisation et ainsi
par exemple installer des écoles
d'infirmières
les écoles d'ingénieurs d unité du cnrs
voire même des unités militaires lors
des diverses rencontres effectuées sur
les terrains avec les élus et acteurs
locaux des communes rurales des
départements des pyrénées-atlantiques je
suis régulièrement sollicités sur les
problématiques abordées à vesoul les
élus ruraux développer impulse chaque
jour de nombreuses initiatives faut
faire vivre et dynamiser leur territoire
mais ils sont toujours confrontés au
manque de moyens de compétences
d'accompagnement en matière d'ingénierie
pour les mener à bien aussi madame la
ministre pouvez-vous devant cette
assemblée nous apporter des précisions
des compléments à ce que vous nous avez
déjà annoncé
sur les moyens spécifiques qui ont été
déployés par le gouvernement pour mettre
en oeuvre les vingt-et-une nouvelles
mesures annoncées par le comité
ministériel la ruralité 20 14 septembre
dernier je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre parler comme
ministre de l'égalité des territoires et
de la ruralité comme sylvia pinel merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice frédérique espagnac merci pour
votre question je connais votre
attachement aux territoires ruraux et je
veux saluer ici le travail de grande
qualité et l'engagement qui a été le
vôtre pendant les assises des ruralités
que le premier ministre a annoncé il ya
tout juste un an vous avez rappelé
l'ambition du gouvernement pour ces
territoires lors du premier comité
interministériel avec les 48 premières
mesures concrètes qui sont pour
certaines déjà opérationnel et d'autres
qui sont qui sont en cours de
déploiement ces mesures ce que ce soit
celle du premier comité interministériel
ou du second ont pour but de répondre
aux préoccupations qui s'expriment sur
les territoires ruraux vous en avez
donné quelques exemples en matière de
service public en matière de santé en
matière de soutien à l'investissement de
couverture numérique du territoire mais
également en matière d'ingénierie je ne
veux pas reprendre les exemples que j'ai
déjà cité mais pour compléter en termes
de moyens je voudrais vous signaler
l'ouverture du prêt à taux zéro dans
l'ancien dans les centres bourgs des
communes rurales pour permettre à la
fois
de rénover le patrimoine existant mais
surtout d'avoir un dispositif plus
lisible plus efficace pour redynamiser
nos territoires ruraux en ce qui
concerne l'amélioration de l'accès aux
services publics de proximité
nous continuons à déployer des maisons
de services au public pour atteindre
atteindre l'objectif de 1000 d'ici la
fin de l'année 2016 et grâce au
partenariat que nous avons lancé avec la
poste la première maison ouvrira en
octobre dans le lot en matière de
mobilité et je sais que vous êtes
extrêmement attachés à cette question ça
faisait partie des débats des assises
sur le maintien des petites stations
service indépendantes en milieu rural 12
millions et demi d'euros supplémentaires
y seront consacrés comme des recharge
pour les véhicules électriques l'accès à
la santé est aussi au coeur de nos
priorités avec les maisons de santé mais
aussi avec les contrats d'engagement de
service public avec des étudiants ou des
internes en médecine la formation à
l'aide médicale d'urgence vous le voyez
madame la sénatrice les mesures sont
nombreuses et c'est grâce à un travail
en partenariat avec les élus locaux avec
les acteurs de ces territoires que nous
réussirons à faire vivre cette belle
notion d'égalité des territoires merci
la parole est à françois commeinhes pour
le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci le 30 juillet au cours d'une
conférence de presse le président
socialiste sortant de la région
languedoc roussillon damien alary
annonce avoir obtenu du plus haut sommet
de l'état la création pour son bénéfice
personnel d'un poste de président de
région de léguer un cadeau de matignon
pour oublier la première vice présidence
régionale qui lui était promise mais
quand douloureuse accord électoral entre
le ps et le prg a cédé à l'actuel
ministre du logement dans la foulée
kléber mesquida député ps et président
du département de l'hérault déclare le
véhicule législatif et trouver car
automne le parlement doit se pencher sur
la question de la coordination des
territoires c'est ensuite le premier
ministre en personne en déplacement à
vauvert le 11 juin qui officialise cette
présidence déléguée présenter qu'encore
comme une création je cite manuel valls
dans le cadre des grandes régions nous
engagerons par la loi une présidence
déléguée pour que chaque territoire
regarde sa force et d'annoncer lui aussi
une loi pour l'automne hier pourtant à
l'assemblée ce même premier ministre a
été contredit par vous même monsieur le
guen qui avait affirmé que cette
présidence délayé existait déjà dans la
loi en évoquant un échelon intermédiaire
alors permettez moi d'essayer de
comprendre si je décrypte ces propos
s'il s'agit seulement d'adapter
maintenant les règlements intérieurs
pour doter une vice-présidence de
délégation générale quel rétropédalage
le gouvernement aurait-il entendu la
colère des élus et des citoyens face à
la mascarade estivale de la loi delgal
harry ne pouvons penser comme premier
ministre puisse annoncer publiquement
l'inscription d'un projet de loi pour je
cite encore la création d'une présidence
déléguée sans le mettre en oeuvre j'en
conclus que le gouvernement a donc bel
et bien reculer quant à mobiliser le
parlement pour voter une loi de
complaisance pour un intérêt particulier
le sénat n'aurait pu accepter cette
indécence ma question sera donc simple
monsieur le ministre alors que vous
preniez ici même l'an passé la
rationalisation de la carte régionale et
des dépenses avec une baisse drastique
des dotations pouvez vous avancer les
contours cette présidence déléguée
évoqué hier assemblée nationale ses
compétences son positionnement au sein
de l'exécutif et les moyens financiers
afférents sera t'elle par exemple dotées
d'un cabinet alors que le premier nice a
été publiquement contredit hier la faut
conclure par vous-même me confirmez vous
que le gouvernement l'a bel et bien
reculer qu'il n'y aura pas de loi créant
le poste de présidente de région délégué
contrairement aux déclarations publiques
de monsieur manuel va
pour la parole était monsieur jean marie
le guen en charge des relations avec le
parlement aussi le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je vais parler avec des gants
évidemment pour vous répondre en vous
disant que je ne suis pas sûr que tous
nos téléspectateurs et bien compris
l'ensemble de votre question néanmoins
néanmoins je voulais vous remercier
d'avoir cité des éminents élus
représentants des territoires de votre
région qui sont effectivement candidat à
de futures élections et je n'ai pas
compris si vous alliez les soutenir mais
peut-être en tout et à cause que mes
réponses vont vous aider à faire votre
décision en tout cas je voudrais
apporter quelques précisions
effectivement regard des interrogations
qui sont les vôtres effectivement vous
avez raison le gouvernement dans le
débat à propos des régions à la demande
d'un certain nombre de régions s'étaient
interrogés sur la nécessité de légiférer
pour la création d'un poste de président
délégué notre analyse juridique
maintenant est très claire vous le savez
ce n'est pas nécessaire et cela ressort
du droit actuel tel qu'il existe à tel
point d'ailleurs vous l'avez site est
effectivement en côte d'or le président
sauvadet a mis en place pour son
département une telle disposition et
plus encore plus près de vous encore le
département de la vienne présidé par
monsieur bruno belin a effectivement
décidé de la même façon de la création
d'une présidence déléguée qui est
intermédiaire entre l'ensemble des vices
présente le premier vice président et le
président de la région les régions qui
le souhaitent et les régions qui le
souhaitent qu'elles soient ou non issu
de la fusion du 1er janvier 2016
pourront donc également usé de cette
faculté je voulais vous rassurer
monsieur le sénateur cette souplesse
pourrait se révéler tout à fait
nécessaire pour la fusion notamment de
plusieurs régions dans les grandes
régions cela permettra de faciliter
l'insertion de ces régions de ces
territoires dans en s'assurant que l'
équilibre entre les différents
territoires qui composent ces nouvelles
grandes régions sera préservé alors
évidemment et contrairement à ce que
j'ai pu lire cette fonction ne
présentera aucun surcoût pour les ré ont
tout d'abord parce que le vice-président
délégué fera partie de l'ensemble du
nombre de vice présidents ensuite parce
que le président délégué ne disposera
pas de moyens particuliers
supplémentaires et je vous rappelle et
ça devrait être surtout cela qui vous
donnera satisfaction que les treize
grandes régions métropolitaines à
diviser par deux le nombre de vice
présidents et les indemnités versées à
ce titre seront donc aussi divisé par
deux voilà monsieur le scénario
concluant scission je conclus là dessus
qu'ils vont dans le sens de la
construction de la nouvelle carte de
france des régions que nous avons mis en
oeuvre la parole
est maintenant un monsieur stéphane
ravier par la réunion administrative les
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste aucun
gros vous avez la parole merci monsieur
président de marque à sion s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre ma question porte sur un sujet
qui a été abordé ici main mais hier soir
mais ici comme à l'assemblée aucun
parlementaire du front national n'a eu
voix au chapitre
même si le front national il en a été
beaucoup question hier dans la bouche de
nos collègues de gauche et d'extrême
gauche l'un d'eux profitant même pour
calomnier le maire de beaucaire julien
sanchez il sort a dû répondre le mans le
moment voulu vous aviez restreint
monsieur le ministre le débat d'hier
soit aux réfugiés mais c'est une
hypocrisie de plus car précisément nul
nul ne sait qui dansaient foule immense
mérite vraiment le statut de réfugié il
faut nommer les choses dire aux français
que nous sommes face à un mouvement de
fond et pour reprendre l'expression d'un
ancien président de la république face à
une nouvelle invasion que nul ne peut
plus nier sauf vous apparemment quand
d'autres et abandonné l'idéologie pour
la réalité et commence à se défendre et
à défendre les intérêts de leurs
compatriotes
que faites vous a pas ouvrir des numéros
verts et dicter aux peuples d'europe et
des quotas permanence est obligatoire de
clandestins seraient partir à marseille
à marseille à un habitant sur quatre
voies sur 3 avoir sur quatre vit en
dessous pendant du seuil de pauvreté
trente mille demandes de logements
sociaux sont en souffrance
la politique d'immigration massive mener
tant par la droite que par la gauche a
fracturé la vie le haut point d'en faire
une place forte du salafisme au niveau
national ce sont déjà 150 mille sdf 3
millions de mal logés et 6 millions de
chômeurs et malgré ce bilan
catastrophique qui devrait vous
convaincre d'agir pour nos compatriotes
d'abord vous obstinez à garantir aux
clandestins une protection sociale
gratuite et des logements prioritaires
vous contribuez ainsi est largement vous
aussi à faire du pays des droits de
l'homme le pays du des droits de l'autre
et dans votre europe qui condamne autant
monsieur sorbonne parce qu'il défend
l'intérêt de ses compatriotes qui passe
pour la défense de ses frontières c'est
on reproche que l'on ne vous fera pas
d'où mes questions monsieur le ministre
quand allez vous enfin agir pour les
causes de 6 sur les causes de ces flux
qui sont catastrophiques pour ces pays
comme pour les nôtres quand allez vous
aider ces populations en vivre en paix
chez elle en commençant par éradiquer
l'état islamique quand allez vous en
faire établir nos frontières et quand
allez vous raccompagner aux frontières
l'immense majorité des clandestins qui
ne sont pas éligibles à l'asile
bref monsieur le ministre temps
allez-vous en fait réagir ans ministre
de l'intérieur et plus en ministre de
l'extérieur pourrait tourner la parole
et au ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve
monsieur le sénateur ravier d'abord
merci pour cette question qui est un
modèle d'humanité d'esprit de nuances de
finesse et de réalisme par rapport aux
problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés vous appelé le gouvernement à
prendre un certain nombre de décisions
sur des sujets je vais vous répondre
très clairement d'abord
il n'est qu'à voir la vidéo qui circule
sur internet concernant les visites
effectuées par le maire de béziers dans
des appartements où sont des étrangers
venus de syrie et d'irak et qui sont
visiblement en besoin de protection pour
comprendre que vous vous ne distinguez
pas entre les réfugiés et les migrants
économiques irrégulier vous êtes
simplement le parti de la haine et vous
mettez tous les étrangers dans la même
approche avec une volonté d'exclusion
qui n'est pas celle de la majorité pour
ne pas dire de l'unanimité de ceux qui
sont ici à l'exception de ceux que vous
êtes vous même et votre question l'a
bien montré elle était inspirée par un
ressort et un seul le rejet et la
convocation des instincts nous sommes
dans une situation particulière avec des
flux migratoires qui conduisent des
femmes des hommes qui sont victimes de
persécutions abject de la part du
califat de la haine à venir en europe
pour échapper à ces persécutions et je
vous le dit les yeux dans les yeux
l'honneur de l'europe l'honneur de la
france conformément à la tradition
multiséculaire de notre pays depuis 1793
c'est d'ouvrir ses portes à ces hommes
et à ces femmes qui sont persécutés et
de ne pas tenir le discours que vous
venez de tenir et de ne pas avoir le
comportement abject dont un certain
nombre d'élus qui vont dans les
appartements où sont ces réfugiés pour
leur dire textuellement vous n'êtes pas
bienvenu chez nous eh bien tant que ce
gouvernement sera là et tente la france
sera la france dans le rassemblement de
toutes les formations politiques
républicaines qui sont ici la france
ouvrira ses bras à ceux qui sont
persécutés chez eux voilà la première
réponse la deuxième réponse c'est que
lorsqu'il s'agit d'agir contre le
terrorisme et contre ce qui représente
un danger pour le pays c'est sur nous
qu'il faut compter et pas sur vous parce
que lorsque nous avons présenté la loi
contre le terrorisme vous avez voté
contre vous avez voté contre
l'interdiction administrative des des
sites internet vous avez voté contre le
pnr vous avez voté contre la loi
renseignement c'est à dire qu'à chaque
fois que nous proposons des solutions
pour combattre les terroristes vous y
opposez parce que ce qui vous intéresse
ce ne sont pas les solutions ce sont les
problèmes parce que le problème c'est le
terreau sur lequel vous propose vous
prospérer et bien nous nous sommes
républicains nous cherchons des
solutions nous combattons les
terroristes
nous sommes dans la fermeté mais nous
continuerons être dans l'humanité puis
deux minutes
je
je vais suspendre
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise assez orcas pour la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi de
modernisation
dames et messieurs les ministres merci
de votre présence
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve tout de suite pour on refait la
séance